et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous ou
alexandra turquie en ce cas mallet
bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau
merci d'être là vous êtes chanteuse
lyrique vous êtes ukrainienne vous vivez
ici en france depuis une vingtaine
d'années et vous vous engagez à votre
façon pour soutenir la résistance en
ukraine enfin en parler dans un instant
avant cela je voudrais qu'on écoute
quelque chose
[Musique]
s'il ya moins de deux heures au coeur de
kiev sur la place centrale de la ville
ce qu'on vient d'entendre dans cette
ville fantôme c'est l'hymne national
ukrainien qui dit entre autres choses ni
la gloire ni la liberté de l'ukraine ne
sont mortes j'imagine que c'est
quelqu'un nine qui résonne
particulièrement ces jours ci oui en
fait l'histoire de l'ukraine elle est
particulière parce que pendant les
siècles
notre payer
j'ai vécu dans la résistance parce que
cette histoire elle est compliquée et
jusqu'aujourd'hui voilà c'était
expérience de la résistance et hino sert
beaucoup
m'ont payé c'est un pays qui n'est
jamais dans son histoire ne voulut ne
faisait pas des interventions vous
voulez pas conquérir des autres pays
c'est assez rare et par contre elle
était toujours confrontés les invasions
de côté et il voulait protéger et garder
ça ça andry quittez
donc cette musique et on vient d'écouter
maintenant même pour les gens qui
comprend pas les paroles je crois qu'ils
aient grâce à la musique seul c'est très
compréhensible parce qu'il a cette
fierté
hélas cette force des
verts
cette force de conviction des ics rien
de porter leur culture et passer ce
message musical
déclaré sa présence voilà sur sur terre
en qu'hier vous êtes ici à paris
alexandra toute chose qui a maillé je
crois que votre dernier séjour en
ukraine remonte à il ya quelques mois au
mois de septembre votre famille est dans
les faubourgs de kiev je crois verbe ou
de chats est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles d'eux comment vont-ils bon
j'essaye de ne pas déranger la nuit
j'espère qu'ils arrivent à dormir 6 e
permet le
lin
les conditions situation actuelle parce
que malheureusement où habite ma soeur
avec sa fille dès 6 ans elle est
compagne commencé des premières journées
de de l'après midi déjà les hélicoptères
commencé bombardé à un report
de lysine antonov qui est
1,4 km
l'immeuble de ma soeur donc ils ont
entendu tout ça et malheureusement ça
continue ça reste c'est cette territoire
c'est parti d'ukraine les lieux de
combat constant donc je m'inquiète
beaucoup je
j'échange des messages tous les jours
plusieurs fois par jour dès que je peux
voilà comment on supporte ici ce qu'il
se passe là bas nous les ukrainiens ici
d'abord je veux dire que
nous sommes tous mobilisés tout de suite
et nous sommes très touchés que nous
avons reçus très forts soutiens ici des
deux
la part des français ou des gens qui
habitent à en france aussi c'est un an
nous avons vu ça pendant toutes les
manifestations qui étaient organisées
d'abord par par le
mini spectacle du paris et cetera donc
c'est pas les ukrainiens qui ont brisé
cette manifestation s'était tout de
suite
7,7 et gestes des soutiens comment est
ce que vous allez ici bas je voulais
dire que l'autre façon de nous engager
c'est
nous avons lancé des campagnes de
collecte des dons au ruc rennes aussi
également un presqu'en certainement
soutenu par parler
et les administrations locales etc nous
organisons aussi de concert choeur et
akingbala notamment jeudi je crois au
centre culturel ukrainien ici à paris je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur la
résistance et chrétienne que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure comment est ce
que vous vous expliquer comment est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer la force
de cette résistance ukrainienne là-bas
la force jeu que
j'explique parce que elle est tout à
fait naturel
bon je vais peut-être commencer un peu
loin mon premier diplôme d études
supérieures c'est être nos musiques au
logis et
nous avons étudié que la culture ses
formes selon le conditions géographiques
donc ces peuples qui vivent dans la
nature dont les pays et leurs langues 16
comme langue de tout n'importe lesquels
pays donc on en importe lesquels nation
pour moi c'est une déclaration de une
responsabilité un devant ses terres
cette partie des terres où ils vivent
donc pour moi et la culture se fait
partie de de cette déclaration et les
ukrainiens qu'ils sont blancs maintenant
sur ses terres ils ont décidé à défendre
il à défendre défendre kung qu'on
comptera quelque chose étrangère qui ne
correspond pas alors qu'on vous de
conviction où s'arrête la responsabilité
ou en tout cas qui pourraient peut-être
cohabiter pacifiquement c'est tout un
pays qui est sous la menace des bouées
aujourd'hui ses habitants évidemment son
patrimoine aussi on pense à odessa qui
en partie classé au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco on a vu ces jours-ci
également ces images des oeuvres du
grand musée deux livres qui est connu
dans le monde entier des oeuvres d'art
nous avons eu d'histoire c'est pas grave
c'est le micro qui est tombé qui sont
mises à l'abri en urgence quand vous
voyez ces images ces oeuvres qui sont
empaquetés ce patrimoine en danger
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque
moi je trouve que osé détruire quelque
chose comme ça ce qui appartient à la
culture du monde dont un tiers de
la terre entière sait est une crime
contre l'humanité moi je suis triste et
très touché que vous ont plu j'ai lu que
dans une petit musée où local où ils
avaient deux des oeuvres d'une
d'une artiste est aussi connu pour le
monde entier c'est une artiste
autodidacte mari après match en cours
dont les situations menaçantes et les
employés de s'amuser ils ont en partie 1
chez eux avec les autres ils ont réussi
de les préserver notons que c'est
alors
alors donc dans la mesure de leurs
possibilités c'est un geste héroïque et
d'envols à mesure de vos possibilités à
vous on le disait ce concert demain
à la part dont centre culturel ukrainien
ici à paris qu'est ce que peut la
musique dans ces moments là musique donc
c'est après demain après demain voyez
joly parle déjà moi je trouve que le
rôle de
de la diplomatie culturelle c'est
quelque chose très puissant et très très
important parce que les musiciens il
maîtrise les vocabulaires
international qui est qui peut passer le
message est loin et
donc ce concert
et l'europe et on nous on est
là un oui nous aurons à un pianiste
français qui est tout de suite il a
répondait pour participer
donc il y à 7
cette collaboration internationale et
ses soutiens il nous allons proposer aux
la musique et criait et françaises et
donc
je trouve que ce dialogue et il montre
que les gens se comprennent dans ces
situations justement à propos de
dialogue une dernière question je
voudrais qu'on parle du chef d'orchestre
russe qui s'appelle tugan sokhiev il
était jusqu'ici directeur musical du
théâtre du bolchoï à moscou et de
l'orchestré national du capitole à
toulouse ici en france il a démissionné
de toutes ses fonctions se disant
victime de la culture d'annulation je le
cite disant sa certitude qu on lui
demanderait bientôt de choisir entre
tchaïkovski à stravinsky
beethoven brahms et debussy qu'est ce
que vous en pensez à ce que vous vous
joueriez avec un artiste russe est ce
que vous joueriez de la musique russe
ces jours ci bon
ma propre position envers sa jeu j'ai
quand même je suis d'accord avec ceux
qui exigent aux artistes russes sur ce
moment quand même déclaré hors position
ce qui soutient la guerre c'est pour moi
et ils n'ont pas de place maintenant
pour pour
passer leur message à eux mais les
oeuvres la voilà la musique russe quand
même c'est
c'est un patrimoine aussi importante je
ne sais pas je ne peux pas dire je suis
pas pour vraiment faire cette
extermination de cette partie de la
culture mondiale donc
si vous pouviez en un mot parce que je
crois que le temps nous manque c'est la
journée aujourd'hui danseur
international du droit des femmes d pour
les droits des femmes si vous vouliez
dire en un mot quelque chose aux femmes
ukrainiennes
pour le vin du cru qui sont en ukrainien
comment une mère des enfants français
je dois dire que d'abord
il faut quand même transmettre aux
enfants
la force et
l'importance d'apprendre leur propre
culture parce que plus tard quand ils
vont grandir ça va les porter ça va les
mobiliser dans les moments difficiles
parce que nos origines en fait c'est
notre nos sources nos ressources de nom
de notre pouvoir
message est passé merci beaucoup merci
infiniment à d'être venu ce matin sur le
plateau de paris direct